first you listen
and you learn
and you watch and you wait your
opportunity
and then you when you're given
opportunity you do the best you possibly
can with an opportunity it's easy to be
successful when all the times are good
that's when the times are not good and
how do you bridge that to when the time
start getting good again and i believe
you know if you apply yourself the
american dream is possible for anybody
today
my name is howard smith i'm president of
the wilson by hannah lock company marion
ohio my wife's grandfather mr wilson by
hannah and toy
came through here on a troop train stop
at a canteen stop
and remember the friendliness of the
people in marion so here is where we
came
in 1926 and here's where we are today
almost 100 years later with about 70
employees making padlocks that are used
all over the world
we're seven generation family business
and very proud to be 100 american made i
went to high school
in dayton ohio and about 95 of my high
school class goes on to college so my
parents are going crazy you know at the
end of the whole situation all my
friends are enrolled somewhere you know
and
where's my son going to go what's you
know and he'll still with the
conservative values and the student
guide did this royal bell is beautiful
and they just said this is where we want
you to go
i met my wife my third week at school
her
great-great-grandfather started the
company in brooklyn new york in 1860
with his son todd and shed behind their
house so she didn't want to be in the
business she wanted to be a part of the
business and so she was on the board of
directors you know she was a guidance
counselor marine catholic for over 30
years
she loved her school she loved her
community she loved this company and
people
just loved pam she was kind loving
um just a big heart you know it's always
a place for any student to come to japan
and talk to to her about any situation
and her passion for wilson my handicap
was powerful and infectious and all
everybody knew how much she loved this
place and she built that legacy with my
two daughters and sadly she was she
passed away and after 42 years of
marriage what better way could you carry
on her memory and something she had so
much pride in you know in this company
we make over 5000 locks a day with most
always a job shop it's all made to order
the check specifications of our
customers there's no lock manufacturer
like us in america today they can do the
things we can do with the tolerance we
can do so i'm proud of that proud that
we're made in this country proud that
you know the symbol of lake hill still
talks about you know the conservative
values
and their christian attitude that's why
we run our business with a christian
attitude and in the belief in the
constitution
hillsdale taught me to be a good
corporate citizen i want to give back i
want a place where my daughters can
raise their family i want a place where
my you know my employees can feel good
about themselves when you hire people
and you bring people from other parts of
the country
are you going to bring them to some
place they don't want to live
[Music]
hill still just as that signpost that
that guide
hanging you know the telling his health
is the best way to do things i think i
said before you know the american dream
is alive and well in this country
and i just want to be an example we're
not just a business we're a human
business with human people who care with
respect and dignity you know of each
other and building a culture that's you
know it's it's powerful people walk
through our factories say gee whiz i
mean
everybody has a good attitude they like
what they do they're proud of this
company
it's creating a culprit culture
that
allows people to grow and be something
and be part of that of a larger part of
something than just themselves it's not
just me it's it's all the people that
surround me all the people that have
made this a great company you know like
i couldn't do without all those people
and so i do when i go to the factory
every single day i thank our employees
thank you very much
[Music]
you